Benvenuti in un nuovo episodio del Late Show con Karim Musa, sapete qual'è il miglior lavoro che potreste mai fare nell'ultimo periodo?
Diventare famosi! Eh sì perché più sei famoso più la gente ti regala roba,ti chiedono di partecipare a
interviste, a programmi, fai film e i libri e...
Più sei famoso e più soldi ti lanciano e più soldi hai più sei famoso e più soldi ti lanciano e il miglior trampolino di lancio,
ovviamente, è YouTube. Tutte le più grandi star d'oggi hanno iniziato su YouTube, basti pensare a...
Justin Bieber,
che suonava dalla sua cameretta ed è stato scoperto o tanto famosi come uno qualsiasi degli youtuber che seguite o
famosi tanto quanto la signora del
pellicciotto, non
So se l'avete visto il video di questa signora che si incazza, con i commessi di un negozio e finisce con
Lei che sviene a corpo morto per terra; ecco questo video ha girato talmente tanto che questa signora prima è andata da Barbara D'urso
e adesso fa le serate, dove potremmo scoprire
tutta la verità. E io credo che sotto questo livello di popolarità ci sia soltanto la morte e quindi non vi
piacerebbe diventare famosi come la signora del pellicciotto? Ma come fare? Caricare i video su YouTube?Eheh, chi cazzo ve li guarda
e ci sono solo due modi per rendere popolare un video, o lo fai bello o ti compri
le visual. Sempre più spesso mi capita di beccare tra i
correlati, ma anche in tendenza è capitato, dei video che hanno delle statistiche un pò sballate: video che hanno troppe visual rispetto ai mi piace,
troppe visual rispetto ai commenti o troppi commenti rispetto ai mi piace; c'è da dire che a volte youtube
sbarella e questi numeri vengono sballati, anche da soli senza che tu possa toccare niente, ma
la maggior parte delle volte in realtà si tratta di
visual comprate o like comprati o commenti comprati. E siccome una volta l'anno mi sale il DarkAngelKraft:
ho voluto indagare.
Io vi invito a prepararvi un tè a farvi dei biscotti e a tenervi forte, perché voi non immaginereste neanche quanti colpi di scena ha
questo "Diario di un compratore di visual".
Allora la prima cosa che ho deciso di fare era
controllare nelle regole di YouTube se ci fosse scritto qualcosa riguardo alle visual comprate da siti esterni...
E c'è: in una pagina del supporto di google, con tanto di triangolo giallo con punto esclamativo
all'interno, c'è scritto le visualizzazioni generate da aziende e servizi di terze parti non verranno conteggiate
o prese in considerazione, su YouTube e potrebbero portare azioni disciplinari nei confronti del tuo account,
incluse la rimozione
del video o la sospensione dell'account. Quindi questa dovrebbe essere la risposta alla primissima domanda che è venuta in mente a tutti quanti:
è "legale" comprare visual su YouTube da altri siti? In teoria
nnno, nel senso che tu puoi anche farlo ma quello che succede poi sono cazzi tuoi, ma questo ovviamente non mi
ha fermato per la scienza questo e altro quindi sono andato a navigare sul web per trovare tutti i siti italiani che vendono
visualizzazioni e oibo quanti ce ne sono con una velocissima ricerca
Su google ne ho trovati subito più o meno una dozzina e ci sono due tipi di visualizzazioni che si possono comprare
Quelle con i bot che sono quelle più
Facili e più economiche che arrivano istantaneamente e quelle definite da alcuni siti
vere che però ci mettono
Mesi ad arrivare ma non finisce qui ovviamente perché tu da questi siti puoi comprare. Le visual ma puoi comprare anche
commenti like e
Dislike e uno potrebbe chiedersi perché dovrei comprare dei dislike perché dovrei essere così scemo da comprarmi dei dislike
Perché dovresti comprarli a te quando poi
bombardare di dislike il video di un'altra persona o
E beh  certo perché nella maggior parte di questi siti tu devi soltanto mettere
quello che vuoi comprare e un link al video non c'è scritto da nessuna parte che devi dire di chi sia al video o
Confermare che sia tuo basta che metti un link e per 30 euro puoi comprarti anche articoli
Su blog giornali online e volendo c'è questa opzione puoi comprare questa cosa qui
Se vuoi essere extra triste comunque in questo primo giorno decido di comprare
100.000 visual in un sito che non costa così tanto come gli altri ma
Il tempo di erogazione ed alle 10mila e 30mila visual al giorno che è quello che mi serve cioè risultati immediati
Il secondo passo è ovviamente creare un canale da zero perché non voglio casini sui miei di canali e quindi vado
Su google e creo zia angela ricette semplici e facili.  Sesso uomo ovviamente  perche sono un cretino
semplicemente perché adesso vanno abbastanza
Ma volevo un argomento che fosse abbastanza facile infatti creo anche un video di ricette. La pizza fatta in casa
Le ricette di zia angela e siccome non volevo far vedere me dentro il video è uno di quei video fatti con
Le scritte e lo sfondo culinario con una musichetta free of copyright su youtube però questo video vi
Sarebbe servito per testare la compravendita di visual quindi non l'ho fatto proprio lineare ci
Ho messo dentro sempre qualcosa di mio
E ho fatto questo un po perché sono una persona malata da un certo punto di vista ma anche perché
Mi sono chiesto durante questo a questa prima giornata
Ma I siti che comprano le visual lo guarderanno il video magari guardandolo dicono
No non posso darti visual su un video così mezzo demoniaco mezzo no
Quindi lasciamo perdere la risposta è se ne sbattono i coglioni quindi carico il video e vado a comprare per
149,99 euro 100.000 visualizzazioni e basta così non mi rimaneva altro che aspettare
Aggiornamento del giorno dopo alle 9.03 minuti del mattino. Del 9 febbraio
sono arrivati le prime visual sono pochine sono
2.757 numero particolare devo dire ma sono arrivate sono molto emozionato non vedo l'ora per I prossimi giorni o alle prossime ore
spero non ci mettono tanto
aggiornamento delle dieci meno 10 sempre del 9 febbraio si sono aggiornate le visual adesso sono
9.719 bravi aggiornamento fatto dieci minuti dopo quello precedente quindi sono le 10, del mattino sempre del 9 febbraio
ho scoperto una cosa
Andando nei nelle statistiche in tempo reale ho scoperto che le visualizzazioni non solo 9.000 e rotte ma sono circa
22mila quindi sono arrivate tutte di getto nelle prime ore del mattino ma youtube non
Le sta non riesce ancora ad aggiornarle in tempo reale e questo poteva creare un problema perché in un canale dove
Appena creato dove non c'è traffico di alcun tipo né commenti né mi piace negli scritti avere tutte tutto quel boom di visualizzazioni
Avrebbe potuto portare all'attenzione di youtube il problema
Sempre il 9 febbraio alle
15 e 15 è arrivato il primo commento quindi vuol dire che e finito da qualche parte nei correlati e qualcuno
L'ha aperto e ha solo quasi 20.000 visualizzazioni quindi da questo punto di vista
funziona quindi un obiettivo
Del comprare delle visual potrebbe essere finire nei correlati perché se è finito nei correlati video vuol dire che queste
visualizzazioni youtube
Le ha contate
Effettivamente contate tanto che qualcuno ha commentato il video e lo ha anche visto il video è vero che durava 20 secondi però
Congratulazioni. Che cos'è quella cosa che si vede alla fine del video e io ovviamente non potevo dire ah si lo correggo
Ho fatto il finto tonto e ho risposto quale. Io non. Vedo nulla e la risposta, non
Ha tardato ad arrivare al secondo 12 c'è una strana figura
Segnalerò a youtube il video è tanti auguri vai vai prova segnalare. I video youtube voglio vedere quando ti rispondono
Ho fatto un errore ho fatto un errore e mi è stato rimosso il video e non credo mi sia stato rimosso per le visual
Comprate ma perché qualcuno appunto come vi avevo fatto vedere ha
Segnalato il video per il contenuto in mezzo alla ricetta che effettivamente ci sta perché è una ricetta quello la guarda gente come
magari famiglie e bambini compresi bambini sono una ricetta per la pizza fatta in casa e si ritrova una roba demoniaca porca di una
puttana lo so non so cosa fare non, so
E domenica 11 febbraio e sono in ufficio sono da solo in tutta la struttura perché domenica e sono le quattro di pomeriggio
e
Perché non, so cosa fare ma. Devo trovare una soluzione perché
L'esperimento non può finire così
Quindi cercherò non lo so
non, lo, so sai cosa faccio quasi quasi scrivo al sito e gli chiedo, se è possibile o
Avere parte dei soldi indietro perché comunque 30 mila visualizzazioni sono arrivate oppure le rimanenti
70.000 poterle spostare in un altro video e fortunatamente sono stati molto gentili la risposta è stata. No ti attacchi al cazzo
E dopo un attenta analisi sono giunto alla conclusione che... che vuoi che siano 150 euro spendiamo
le
Anche di più per provare a crearne un altro di video sempre un video della pizza fatta in casa
Fatto da zia angela però senza satana all'interno a sto giro compro
100.000 visual e
500 like dallo stesso sito di prima ma dicendo di comprare per provare anche 25
commenti da un altro sito però ha tra l'altro una particolarità, del sito
Dove ho comprato. I commenti c'è una specie di mini gioco per comprarli te li devi scrivere tutti e 25 tu oppure
puoi pagare
15 euro in più rispetto
Al prezzo dei commenti e gli
Dici bene o male cosa vorresti farti sentir dire e te li scrivono loro e allora così mi sono tirato
Su le maniche ho iniziato a scrivere
25 commenti
Completamente a caso ma bene o male inerenti al video carico il video compro tutto e torno a casa
Io non mi posso distrarre un attimo che qui sono arrivate
26.000 visual alle 15.01 del 12 febbraio saremo a te
26.100 visual e I primi due commenti che ho comprato c'è un problema però
Sono stranieri sono commenti stranieri io non è che sono finito in tendenza in russia
è possibile
Commenti in russo ci stavano scervellando per capire perché cazzo fossero arrivati commenti
Russi vuoi vedere che dei 25 commenti arrivano tipo da utenti russi
Fasulli e quindi youtube e li traduce in automatico dall'italiano, al russo e quindi quelli sono due commenti che ho comprato no no
Oppure
sotto il consiglio
Del mio collega abbiamo provato a tradurre il commento più votato sotto il video è il commento che ho notato è questo
Tendenze sul serio e 102 puttana in navigazione web quello poi mi sa che l'ha tradotto male quindi forse siamo internet sia lui sia per davvero io stavo scherzando è
WTF Possibile che fossimo arrivati in tendenza in russia andiamo a controllare nelle tendenze russe e non c'eravamo
ovviamente probabilmente c'è stato qualche altro problema
Ma la giornata non era ancora finita nuovo aggiornamento delle 17.07 sempre del 12 febbraio
Sono arrivati. I commenti sono arrivati commenti. Che ho comprato e che sono arrivati tutti insieme
troppo strano però sono giustificati perché ho
32.000 visuale ai quei commenti ci stanno bene effettivamente ci stanno bene non che siano arrivati tutti nello stesso minuto
Non sono ancora arrivati tutti ma
Cinque tutti si tutti insieme e in quel momento ho fatto una cosa che forse non avrei dovuto fare
Ho detto guarda un po questi commenti sono tutti con avatar diversi tutti con il nome
Verosimile perché io personalmente da questi siti mi aspettavo
utenti senza avatar cycle avatar grigio base con numeri e lettere maiuscole e minuscole come come codici captcha
Come utenti e ho fatto una cosa che non avrei dovuto fare ne ho aperto uno allora ovviamente questo canale non aveva contenuti
però era iscritto a circa una quarantina
Di canali youtube
Allora, ne apre un altro è anche lui era iscritto ad una quarantina di persone e il 90 per cento dei canali era lo
Stesso, apro il terzo stessa cosa e allora mi è venuto in mente
siccome dal sito da cui
Ho comprato, I commenti puoi anche comprarti gli iscritti gli account che usano per creare commenti falsi
Li usano anche per creare iscritti falsi quindi io ho beccato
40 persone che comprano iscritti però appunto essendo solo tre canali italiani pure piccolissimo detto non me
Ne frega nulla di farlo vedere quindi non ve li faccio vedere però solo lì ma sentire qua l'aria no
aria che sta diventando pesante l'aria di questo video santo cielo
Questa giornata
il colpo di scena
aggiornamento del 13 febbraio alle 9.27 del mattino
Ho scoperto dove siamo finiti in tendenza
Non è in russia ma è uno dei paesi che parlano la lingua o comunque una variante del russo che
l'ucraina siamo in tendenza in ucraina in diciannovesima
con il video le ricette di zia angela la pizza veloce fatta in casa
Oh, oh mio dio mio dio vi. State chiedendo come l'abbia scoperto per
innanzitutto è arrivato un altro
commento che veniva tradotto in pizza e
Deliziosa ma non per le nostre tendenze
Quindi da lì ho detto no non è possibile che sia una coincidenza che un altro commento in russo parli delle tendenze
Andiamo a vedere gli analytics del video innanzitutto, dall italia sono arrivate soltanto
55 visual è sopra di me ovviamente c'erano paesi come pakistan filippine
lettonia uzbekistan
moldavia india
kirghizistan,
Kirghizistan il kirghizistan è un aspro paese dell'asia centrale che sorge lungo la via
Della seta a perfetto perfetto qui è un ottimo paese per fare
delle visual sulla pizza fatta in casa e al primo posto con il 27 per cento di visual totali del video c'è
l'ucraina quindi per tutti gli ucraini che stanno guardando questo video vi baxter vita
Slovo vedi tale scopo in definitiva è
possibile fingere di essere famosi
Ma come nei film di shyamalan
mancano ancora I twist finali
Questo
14 febbraio questo san valentino
Alle 13 09 non
ho fatto in tempo ad entrare in ufficio che
C'è stato un nuovo colpo di scena ero arrivato a circa 40.000 visual quindi me ne mancavano altre
60mila per arrivare a 100.000 e invece oggi mi ritrovo
8900 me ne hanno tolte praticamente
32.000
mi hanno tolto 32.000 visual
Credo pulizia di youtube non son sicuro, non?
So come funzioni ma a quanto pare sono stati
Sono state tolte queste visual qui. Sono qui da un certo punto di vista ottimo vuol dire che youtube controlla queste cose qui
dall'altro, ho perso altri soldi
Giusto per curiosità sono andato a rileggermi le faq. Del sito da cui ho comprato le visual e
Proprio perché I nostri servizi vengono erogati da account e persone reali
Il processo di promozione è totalmente legale e 100 per cento sicuro
Ed ovviamente il giorno dopo o guarda un po i 25 commenti che ho comprato da un altro sito sono spariti
E così come nella famosa puntata dios e dove set saluta anna l'aeroporto piangendo come un disperato
Io con una lacrima che mi solca il viso saluto, I miei quasi
400 euro spesi per fare questo video
so che molti di voi sono lì a
strapparsi I capelli dicendo ma perché stai dicendo queste cose guarda che c'è gente che potrebbe farlo adesso tu
Dicendo glie le hai fatte  scoprire o mio dio e adesso sono abbastanza convinto che chi volesse comprare le visual
Le ha già comprata probabilmente
Lungi da me dirvi che cosa fare voi siete liberissimi
Di usare questi siti qui. Di comprarvi visualizzazioni scritti eccetera e abbiamo visto che è possibile
comprarsi visualizzazioni iscritti like commenti addirittura è possibile fare quello che posso dirvi da
youtuber è che
nessuno è mai diventato diciamo famoso per
mancanza di altri termini che nessuno è mai diventato famoso comprando visual
Nessuno perché per quanto sito vi. Possa dire questi sono utenti reali
interessati ai vostri video, non è
Vero c'è quel sito di cui vi. Ho parlato che ci mette mesi per farvi arrivare viva perché sai come funzionano
Le sue visualizzazioni c'è proprio scritto nelle informazioni. Del sito
mettono il vostro video
dentro spazi pubblicitari di applicazioni gratuite quelle sono visual
probabilmente
effettive perché sono avviso al del video che parte nella pubblicità
Del vostro video che viene inserito di dentro ma di gente che magari sta giocando a un gioco di merda free to play
Dall'app store e si vede partire all'improvviso come pubblicità, non
Il solito mocio per pulire per terra ma il vostro cazzo di video per farvi un esempio
Voi create una torta e volete farla mangiare a più persone possibili e allora voi prendete una persona la legate alla sedia e
Con un martello le ficcate la torta in bocca finché non dice ah ok è buona quello non è un utente attivo e utente che avete
che avete forzato a mangiare la torta
Forzato a guardare il vostro video perché si potrebbe analizzare la situazione e analizzare. I tipi di visualizzazione
I tipi di like I tipi di sito. I tipi di provenienza delle visualizzazioni
Ma questo non è un documentario di netflix
Prendete il video per quello che è: un esperimento. Grazie mille per aver seguito questo video ci vediamo alla prossima!